olympic gold medalist alex kopach is
used to being out of breath behind his
bobsled but last year when the then 31
year old caught covet he felt his breath
taken away like never before i was in
hospital for
five days
i was having oxygen
for about
once i was almost almost two months it
took about four months after he was
released kobach says before he could
breathe normally again at western
university scientists are now a step
closer to figuring out why so these
people look normal clinically and their
chess cts were also quite normal lead
researcher grace porrega and her team
used a special mri five times more
sensitive than a ct scan to zoom in on
kopach's airways what we found was that
exchange of oxygen from the air and the
alveoli into the red blood cells was
abnormally low red blood cells are
responsible for the transportation of
oxygen from your lungs to the rest of
your body any disruption in this flow
triggers your brain to command the lungs
to breathe more resulting in a feeling
of breathlessness of 34 unvaccinated
participants in western study only 12 of
them who had been hospitalized by covid
all had the same abnormality
having an identifiable abnormality
that fits with their symptoms
is
satisfying versus everybody
you know being labeled as somebody who's
suffering from long covet
and you know people telling them it's in
their mind it's a cognitive thing
now researchers hope to understand why
covid is causing this abnormality more
than a year after his boat with the
virus kopachu has recovered hopes
identifying the trigger will lead to
treatments
knowing the severity of some of these
diseases might give us better tools to
work with the recovery process shedding
light on a disease we still know very
little about jamie morocco global news
toronto